I mean the the dominant feature of
British politics in
2023 has been the failure of the
conservatives in general and Mr sunak in
particular to move the dial that labor
lead of around 20 points just stays
solid it doesn't matter what the Tes do
they try a relaunch in the summer they
try a new pitch at their conference they
have an Autumn statement none of it
moves the dial and I think that Mr sunak
is haunted by the fact that he's not a
new leader that's taken over from a
long-standing leader he's a new leader
that's taken over from David Cameron
Theresa May Boris Johnson Liz truss H
and with all that game of musical chairs
it would seem to me that the Tory
credibility is shot to hell and things
won't be any different next year either